hey this is the best game ever this best
game is the best game ever
let's get my return on hand let's play
this game ever best game ever to any
game where you can drag out the ads is
the best game ever game ever here best
game ever there Felix finally finally
finally mint tea salute Harvey we got
the bed we have the best game ever
okay and I'll tell you why it's the best
game ever because I helped work on it
that's right I'm talking of course about
animal super squat short for ass it's
the best game ever
I made it together with Armand it's our
love child Armand is the guy who came up
with goat simulator that idea and
together
with a fantastic team of double moose
who put their heart and soul into this
we have animals super squad I am
genuinely so proud of this even though I
put barely any effort in it a lot of
people have been asking what what my
role in this game is I can't make games
obviously I'm not a developer but so
I've been more of a creative outlook
produce the game it started off let's
start a game and then I can talk over it
cuz it starts off pretty simple
it's starting hey I love this character
it
we made that puffer fish just cuz
Martell loves puffer fish is so much and
they're so cute I'm getting so
sidetracked god damn it you can play the
puffer fish everybody there you go this
is you know we've been talking about
this game for years
clearly it was a product that went
through rebel mode which was my company
together with Disney but you know you
all know how that story went so I took
over this project independently and then
it became through with double mode it's
a long story I'm just amazed that it
survived a whole wall street journal'
apocalypse and all that
I'm just so proud and excited that it's
finally finally out so the game starts
off pretty simple it's sort of inspired
by trials and happy wheels we really
wanted to make a game where the
community that's the biggest aspect of
it and a lot a lot of time and effort
that went into making the level editor
which I'll show you later where you can
really make some crazy chaotic [ __ ] and
personally I can't wait for to play you
guys levels and maps and whatever it's
gonna be so much fun I can't wait to see
what the community of this game will be
I have a lot of it's a lot of stuff for
me to say and a lot of thoughts coming
in at once I don't know should I just
play the game and shut the [ __ ] up or
Adam or I can suite it very nice by the
way all right I lost the vehicle but
we're gonna we're gonna continue as per
usual because who needs a vehicle when
you can just walk this is realistic
walking animations here we really went
all for realism in this game as you can
tell because the Apple just exploded so
the game is in early access so it starts
up with this area we have a ton of new
other airs coming up let's do it
let's do something more advanced celosia
we have Ethan sprayed up a plagiarized
character
oh we get the new vehicle as well we do
this one can fly but you can also tell
we take everything very seriously in
this game this is practically the
walking simulator of video games
we really hope this one will take over
all of them this is actually the first
time I ever played this my boss I don't
know how this will go
I think I'm doing a pretty swell job is
this this is run by [ __ ] is it get some
good speed
oh nice very nice ten out of ten
look at this you're not gonna you're not
gonna want to know the game you know
what else are you gonna do with life you
you're gonna want to play this game if
you haven't bought at least twenty
copies yet then what are you okay I'm
asking
I made it everyone I made it look at
that look how happy is we we feat the
level that would that means we beat the
level okay great
oh we look at you oh we have a ton of
unlockable we are not the face everyone
incredible now we ever had everyone this
changes everything
oh wow that's just great this is this is
how you want to play the game this is it
look at that you know I'm pretty much
the best player in the world
at this game or at least top ten right
now because the game isn't out yet I
mean it's out today so I won't be
lasting very long like I told you guys
the game is all about the community
let's play someone made this one the
game isn't even out yet who the hell is
making ding dong version - this looks
legit whoa someone says it's it's a user
created level I guess we'll go down
that's so cool oh no no no oh my god no
I lost my wheels damn it
ah okay it's fine if we can still do
this ten that okay okay we lost the
vehicles that's fine we never mind stop
come on come on yes yes yes no yes no
this is the most annoying level okay
okay okay
perfect perfect perfect perfect perfect
perfect perfect
wait for the earth go go go go yes just
go burn I hate this game you know I'll
take it all back this game should never
have been made nice and easy
we're fine we're fine we're finally fine
now what now what yes oh okay well here
we are in the wonderful level editor you
can do all kinds of stuff it's pretty
simple to use you just pretty much just
click anything you think will happen
will happen control paste all that kind
of stuff
delete deletes you click on it we can
change the conveyor speed what happens
if we put the five fifty fifty thousand
whatever okay well great that's just
great it's sometimes you should ask how
about we add a little low angle on it
now we're gonna just keep making that
steadily just like I just like a nice
little downhill a nice breeze in the
wind how will that work pretty flaw
let's say I would say okay now we're
gonna add some why don't I have some
mines right how does this work
that did not work at all as intended I'm
gonna call this one PD pies challenge if
you guys can beat this you're pretty
good at the game not gonna lie you're
pretty good at the game this is
practically impossible
this is the best this is the best level
I made this level it's really good
clearly I have no skill yeah dammit I
didn't know they were pop wow I can't
wait to see what you guys are gonna make
cuz you're so much more talented than I
am this alright so this is a work in
progress it's probably the best map ever
in my opinion it's taken me a couple
years it's sick
got my job okay I'm gonna be honest I
have no talent in making levels that's
why I want you guys to make some levels
I would love to play them for a video I
think it could be super fun it's a huge
part of the game the community aspect
and they and I can't wait to see what
you guys gonna take this this is it's
probably one of the biggest projects I
ever worked on myself and honestly it
would mean the world to me if you guys
decided to support this it's only 10
bucks cuz it's in early access we're
gonna improve everything about it keep
making stuff based on you guys
suggestions and what you guys enjoy and
all that stuff I would really appreciate
if you check it out like it's in the
description and hopefully we can keep
making this thank you very much and bro
fitting